Oh mein headset, es kommt, ach du scheiße, oh ne, keine Schimpfwörter heute, ist ja netter
Stream.
Ich muss mal kurz mein headset entknoten, Sack.
So Leute, Moment, ich höre noch nichts, ich habe das headset noch nicht eingestöpselt.
So, jetzt passt alles.
Also, was ist, was hat es, Moment Leute, ich muss, ich kann, ich bin gerade zu 3-Head zum
Lesen richtig.
Was hat es eigentlich bei dir an der Arbeit bezüglich Homeoffice gegeben?
Du meinst, was es Neues gibt oder was ist denn das Letzte, was ich erzählt habe, was
du weißt?
Also ich meine, ich kann jetzt ja schlecht, kann jetzt ja schlecht alles erzählen der
letzten drei Jahre.
Also das Letzte, was ich hier im Stream etwas, ok, also das Letzte, was ich hier im Stream
ein bisschen breiter getreten habe, ist ja, dass es sich bei uns auf der Arbeit sehr schwer
tun, was Homeoffice Regelungen angeht bzw. dass sie eigentlich eine Homeoffice Regelung
haben, aber irgendwie Laufendrückzieher machen.
Ja, genau, das war das Letzte, ja, lasst mal überlegen, was hat sich getan, also offiziell
im Prinzip nichts, außer, dass mittlerweile ein Abteilungsleiter seinen Platz geräumt
hat und an vielen Stellen gerade ziemlich die, ja, die Personalgewechsel ist.
Das hat wahrscheinlich alles nur bedingt mit Homeoffice zu tun, denke ich mal, aber vielleicht
bringt das alles ein bisschen frischen Wind rein, also da haben an vielen Stellen aktuell
keine Leute, keinen Bock mehr, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es unbedingt großartig
was mit Homeoffice in vielen Fällen zu tun hat, aber das hat bestimmt mitgespielt und
es gibt halt immer noch keine offizielle neuen Aussagen, also insofern eigentlich, eigentlich
nichts, ja, ich habe mir das immer noch überlegt, aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht das weiter
großartig verfolgt seit dem letzten Mal, wo ich was erzählt habe, wie gesagt, ich habe
ja was abgesprochen, mal Probearbeitstag, aber da hatte ich ja dann Corona, wo das war
und ich gucke gerade, die meinten, sie melden sich nochmal, haben sie aber noch nicht, vielleicht
sollte ich das mal machen, mal gucken, oh Leute ich habe neue Anfrage, ich habe neue Sponsoring
Anfrage, wollen wir da mal reingucken zusammen, also was haben wir denn hier, von Yu Green,
ist Yu Green nicht irgendein so ein China-Chinesen, Hersteller, Elektronikhersteller, ja, ja,
Longchen Industrial Park, Longhua District Shenzhen, da weißt du, weißt du Bescheid,
also was wollen sie denn, guten Tag Herr Max FPS, ja von denen, ich habe von denen auch
ein paar Sachen, also ich lese das jetzt mal kurz vor, ich gucke mal kurz, ob ich euch
das zeigen kann, ob das überhaupt keck ist oder nicht keck, jaja ist klar, was die wieder
schreiben, okay ich zeige euch das mal, also heute haben wir Yu Green, Yu Green Aira, die
uns schreibt, ich werde mal die E-Mail Adresse anonymisieren kurz, Yu Green Aira schreibt
uns, also ich zeige, ups, was habe ich jetzt hier angeklickt, also folgendes, folgende
Anfrage, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das was ist, schau mal mal, bin ich gespannt, also
Yu Green Aira ist das ganze, das ist bestimmt die echte, die hier in dem Bild, garantiert
mit Sicherheit, also was wollen sie denn hier, das ist Aira von Yu Green, Yu Green Limited
ist ein 2012 gegründetes Hightech Unternehmen, das sich auf Design an der Stelle von Blablabla
und bei Amazon auf Platz 2 in der Kategorie Handy Ladegeräte rangiert, ich bin ein großer
Fan ihres Kanals, die hat nicht ein Video gesehen, falls es überhaupt eine die ist in
Wirklichkeit, nachdem ich Dutzende ihrer YouTube Inhalte gesehen habe, ich schreibe um zu sehen
ob wir eine Zusammenarbeit haben können, im Oktober werden wir ein cooles Produkt auf
den Markt bringen, Yu Green Nexo, Nexode 140W PD 3.2.1 Ladegerät, interessieren sie sich
für eine YouTube Integration für dieses Produkt, das ist ein USB Charger oder, warum will man
ein USB Charger bewerben, hey, ohne Scheiß, ich bewerbe auch ein USB Charger, habe ich
überhaupt kein Problem mit, wenn das, wenn das, ähm, wenn die Kohle stimmt, interessiert
mich, das ist ok, zumal ich habe tatsächlich selbst ein paar Yu Green Sachen, die sind
gar nicht mal so übel, ich habe eine Handy Halterung und ich glaube auch ein USB Hub
und so gedönns, also was haben die denn, PD 3.1 Schnellladen, 140W Max Output des USB
C1 Anschlusses, Leute, Leute, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr was ich antworte, wisst ihr was
ich antworte, ich frage, ob das Ding USB Gen 3.2 Gen 2x2 kompatibel ist oder ob es doch
eher schon 4.0 Gen 3.2 Gen 2x1 kompatibel ist, mal gucken was dann als Antwort kommt,
ich frage dir einfach mal welche USB Standards unterstützt werden, Leute, ich sehe in meinem
Browser keine Twitch Emotes mehr, seht ihr Twitch, ihr seht Emotes, ja, ja, Moment, warum
sehe ich keine Emotes mehr, in meiner Vorschau ist FFZ kaputt, ne, ja, ne, ne, ich sehe,
im Stream seht ihr die, aber tatsächlich, Leute, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz,
ich muss mal kurz reloaden, es ist doch wichtig, es ist doch wichtig, ob Gen 3x2 oder sonst
was, jetzt gehen die Emotes wieder, alles klar, so, was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes
zu bieten, also, was gibt es denn sonst noch, die GAN Technologie, ist das nicht irgendwie
Quick Charge oder sowas, lädt MacBook von 0 auf 56%, das sind wir aber genau, ja, von
0 auf 56%, nicht von 5 auf 55%, von 0 auf 56%, 1,6 Mal schneller als ein 65 Watt Ladegerät,
GAN Technologie, kleiner, leicht, erzeugt weniger Wärme, genauso schnell aufladen wie
das Apple 140 Watt Ladegerät, also, ja gut, ich meine, wenn beides 140 Watt Ladegeräte
sind, würde ich jetzt davon ausgehen, dass es ähnlich schnell lädt, jedoch dank GAN Technologie,
es ist 22% kleiner, folgt über 200, zwei USB-C Ports, ein USB-A Port, ja, ich hoffe
mal, das ist Gen 3x2.x, Q5, lade zwei Laptops und ein Smartphone gleichzeitig, Multisicherheit,
oh, jetzt kommt es, High Security Features, Ukraine Power Dispenser System, bietet intelligente
Leistungsanpassung, das Thermal Guard System misst jede Sekunde 800 Temperaturwerte, jedes
Sekunde 800 Temperaturwerte, den Temperatursensor hätte ich auch gerne, um eine Überhitzung
zu verhindern, am Ende des Mails befinden sich Verweise auf Bericht, wisst ihr was,
ich schicke das mal an meinen Manager weiter, ich mache jetzt ein Ukraine Sponsoring, easy,
weiterleiten, ich mache jetzt Ukraine Sponsoring, wo ist er hier, Moritz, wo steckt er, ne, nicht
der, er ist da gar nicht so bei mir in den Mails, ach so, ne, er ist bei mir für den
Mails auch noch verkehrt, lul, gesendet, habe ich sie mir jetzt geschickt, ja, ok, ok, den
anderen Kram, der andere Kram ist Scam, den zeige ich euch nicht, oh, Wublos, Leute, Leute,
jetzt, ich hab's geschafft auf Twitch, Leute, Wublos bekommt auch schon Anfragen, ich weiß
immer wo die gucken halt, je nachdem was für Namen die schreiben, Wublos bekommt auch,
Wublos hat eine Anfrage bekommen, eine Sponsoring Anfrage per Mail, Leute, Postchamp, da muss
ich jetzt reingucken, hallo Wublos, Achtung, Achtung, was ist das, wir arbeiten im Moment
mit, mit was, oh ne, irgendein free to play Star Trek Game, na, ich weiß ja nicht, oh
ne, oh ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das mach ich net, Russ, Russ, Moskau live, bestimmt einige,
einige Cams, oder, wo was live ist, oder geht da, oder geht da grad irgendwas ab, zeig mal,
ja, aber ich, ich mach das lieber nicht im Stream, auch wer weiß was das ist, ich mach
es mal, ach so, ja, da gehts, da gehts dann halt wirklich ab, tja, mal gucken, was da
so läuft bei den Commodits, was da jetzt rauskommt, Hauptsache ich kann ordentlich
heizen im Winter, Rest ist mir eigentlich egal, Hauptsache es wird nicht noch teurer,
was, 1k, was verlinkt ihr mir da wieder für komische Sachen, Chat, oh der Typ, also ich
habe keine Ahnung was es ist, aber der Typ ist Pog, weil der hat ein Xiaomi Thermostat,
das gleiche was ich auch habe, Alter was ist denn das, das Stream, Mann, Russisches Gas
und jetzt hat er den Herd an, Mann, Alter, aber er hat, also er hat zumindest schon mal
ein gutes Thermometer hier vorne, ja, das Xiaomi Thermometer ist Pog, der hat das Gas
den ganzen Tag an, ja, aber im Ernst, jetzt so viel verbraucht so ein Herd jetzt auch
nicht, als dass das irgendwie ins Gewicht fallen würde, außer, dass seine Rechnung
teuer wird.
Na ja, schon mal was mit Rust gemacht, ja, haben wir doch sogar im Stream, wo bin ich
jetzt, wo bin ich jetzt hier stehen geblieben, ich wollte doch was zu sagen, also zu Homeoffice
habe ich was gesagt, also Leute, demnächst Yu Green Sponsoring, ich mach sogar, ich mach
sogar ein Live Unpacking im Stream, wenn die wollen, dann packe ich, dann packe ich im
Stream, Leute, wir packen 5 USB Hubs aus und ihr schreibt dann in den Chat ganz viel Pog,
Pogchamp, Pogu und dann schicke ich das, dann schicke ich das denen weiter und dann wissen
die, der Wubblos, den kann man krass sponsoren, machen wir Giveaway im Stream, da machen wir,
da machen wir USB Hub Giveaway und Handyhalterung, aber mal gucken, ja ich finde das, wie gesagt
habe ich von denen auch ein paar Sachen, deswegen bin ich da gar nicht so abgemerkt, das zu
machen, die bezahlen halt wahrscheinlich nichts, deswegen wird das, deswegen wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht zustande kommen, die wollen wahrscheinlich nichts bezahlen, so nach dem Motto, zeige den
USB Hub und du bekommst 120 Euro oder so, also für 120 Euro mache ich garantiert kein
Sponsor Video, da muss schon, da muss ein bisschen, ich meine, ich muss ja auch dran
denken, dass die Leute sich das gar nicht gerne angucken, wobei je nachdem wie man das Sponsoring
macht, das schon, geht das eigentlich, wozu brauchst du, brauchst du einen, achso, ja
eigentlich brauche ich den gar nicht, aha, ja Quickmaps ist angesagt, der Rest ist Abwärme
wahrscheinlich, das ist so ein 140 Watt Ladegerät und ein 36 Watt Netzteil oder so, nicht Netzteil,
Heizlüfter, Heizlüfter 36 Watt, der heizt nichts, das gibt vielleicht ein, wenn du
die Hand direkt davor hältst, ein ganz bisschen warmes Lüftchen, das war es dann aber, damit
kriegst du, damit kriegst du einen Lötkolben ganz gut warm, das würde mich auch mal interessieren,
warum die 800 mal pro Sekunde dieses messen müssen, ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe schon
was mit Rust gemacht, wir haben sogar im Stream was mit Rust gemacht schon, aber Chat, ich
muss heute nett sein, ich habe gesagt, heute gibt es keine Schimpfwörter und ich bin zu
allem im Chat nett, also wenn einer was blödes fragt, antworte ich dann vielleicht nett
drauf, weiß ich noch nicht genau, je nachdem was, das ist keine Frage, außerdem stimmt
das, was ist das Problem, gestern kam ein NVMe zu USB Gehäuse von Ukraine zu mir, jetzt
weiß ich, was ich von denen noch habe, ich habe, so ein Ding habe ich mir auch von denen
gekauft und das ist mega warm geworden, was aber wahrscheinlich eher an der SSD lag als
in dem Gehäuse, wieso magst du keinen C++, ich bin einfach zu dumm für C++, das kann
selbstverständlich nicht an C++ liegen, sind wir uns ja einig, C++ ist natürlich die Geistesprache
überhaupt, aber ich bin einfach zu 3Head, um C++ zu verstehen, die wollen ja nicht mehr,
mit denen wollte ich ja schon mal was machen und die haben dann gesagt, ja du musst dieses
Video hier löschen, ich wollte nicht mögen, alter lügen, die wollten, dass ich dieses
Video hier lösche bei NordVPN, wir waren uns schon einig, wir waren uns sogar schon
über das Sponsoring und über den Preis und über das Placement einig, dann haben die
gesagt, Max kannst du dieses Video von deinem Kanal löschen, habe ich gesagt, nee kann
ich nicht und dann wollten sie nicht mehr und die neuen, also ich kriege regelmäßig
weiter Anfragen von NordVPN, aber irgendwie sind die ziemlich pepega, die dir Anfragen,
die antworten dann teilweise nicht oder schreiben ganz vieles Zeug, man weiß nicht so genau,
durch wie viele Translator Schichten diese E-Mails immer gegangen sind, wegen unserer
Atmosphäre, wegen was sonst, geht das überhaupt, mit irgendeinem C-Interface geht das bestimmt,
was sagst du zu den neuen Nvidia Karten, die wurden revealed, wirklich, da habe ich mitgekriegt,
da zeige ich mal, das wusste ich gar nicht, Nvidia hat soeben neue Details zur GeForce
Grafikarten enthüllt, das sind RTX 4090, 4080, das Ding, ich will nicht wissen, Alter, so,
chat, stehen die Preise da drin, stehen die Preise da drin, mal spoilern, stehen die Preise
da drin, lass mich mal raten, na gut, jetzt ist schon, der Chat hat schon gespoilert,
der Chat hat schon gespoilert, okay, ich hätte 1000, ich hätte wahrscheinlich auch
irgendwie 1900, 1800, irgendwie sowas gesagt, aber der Spoiler ist falsch, okay, okay, dann
lass mal überlegen, mehr, dann ist es mehr, 2500, 2500, endlich ist es soweit, ich kann
es kaum erwarten, wieder richtig viel Kohle für eine Grafikkarte auszugeben, oder, oder,
ich muss mal wieder ein paar, ähm, gaming bezogene Videos machen, die gut laufen, also
gaming bezogene Videos, die gut laufen, ist relativ einfach, ich muss einfach eine Runde
über Battlefield flamen, die laufen nämlich immer gut, und dann schicke ich mal an meinen,
falls es den dort überhaupt noch gibt, oder die dort überhaupt noch gibt, an meinen Nvidia
Kontakt, an meine Anfrage, kann ich nicht eine neue Grafikkarte haben, ich mach dann
auch wieder was zu, ähm, hab ich EA Sponsor, ich mein, ich mein, Nvidia, ach nee, du meinst
wegen Battlefield, ja gut, die EA sponsort mich eh nicht, EA wird im Leben mich nicht
mehr sponsoren, nach den letzten drei Battlefield Videos, die wir da gemacht haben, also ich
hab ja zum, ich hab ja zum Battlefield 2042 Release drei sponsort Videos gemacht, und
eins davon war wirklich gut fand ich, mit dem Portal Edit Modus, hat sonst niemand auf
YouTube gemacht, leider war das Spiel scheiß, äh, äh, verbesserungswürdig, ja, hat Defizite
aufgewiesen das Spiel, und dementsprechend musste ich halt nicht so nett sein in den
Videos zu dem Game, also weiter, unschärfen, genau, es muss, es muss, Battlefield muss
noch nachgeschärft werden, da war sicherlich einiges nicht im Scope in der Entwicklung,
paar Sprints verpasst, das Kanban Board war kaputt, nicht agil genug, also lass mal weiter
gucken, das ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal, ich will eigentlich nur wissen was
unab, boah, Alter, 450 Watt, bald braucht man ja wieder 800 Watt, Netzteile, das kannst,
damit kannst du heizen, ich mein das ist in heutigen Zeiten, wo Gas so teuer ist, wahrscheinlich
gar nicht schlecht, also du kannst entweder, äh, teure Gas halten, du kannst aber einfach
ein Gaming PC anlassen und irgendeinen Benchmark laufen lassen nachts, Strom heizen ist wahrscheinlich
billiger, das klingt in Anbetracht der enormen Rechnung beinahe moderat, ok, doppelt so viel
Performance wie eine 3090 spielen, das finde ich gut, das ist dann nämlich endlich mal
wieder was vergleichbar zur 1080ti, die 1080ti war nämlich so schnell, dass du die nächste
Generation eigentlich komplett skippen konntest und die übernächste Generation auch nicht
wirklich gebraucht hast, das wäre dann tatsächlich mal wieder was, ja, da gehe ich von der 1080ti
direkt auf eine RTX 3090, blow the game, Dankeschön, Massive Subscriptions hier, huge, dazu kann
ich nur sagen, und Shadow auch, ich vermute mal, dass man das so ausspricht, Dankeschön
Leute für die Subs, huge Subscriptions, ich find mein Subscriber Sound grad gar nicht
glaub hier, exellent, so Raytracing, gut das juckt mich jetzt persönlich nicht so sehr,
wann erscheinen sie was kostens, los geht es mit der neuen Grafik Speerspitze, am 12.
Oktober, wer sofort zum Start, mach ich, easy, Leute da bin ich nachts am Start, 0 Uhr 1,
hammer ich den Button im Nvidia Shop, richtig BÄM BÄM BÄM, der wird richtig gehämmert
der Hammer, äh nicht der Hammer, der Button, der wird richtig, richtig gehämmert und dann
kauf ich mir neuer Grafiker, wobei ganz ehrlich ich glaube, es bringt gar nichts wenn du den
Button hämmerst, weil 30 Millionen Bybots wieder auf der Webseite sind, gleich 5 Stück,
genau, warum kein Skript, noch besser, noch besser, ich hoffe die ändern an die Seite
nicht, dass es dann kaputt geht, brauche ich Leute, wird gekauft, von der RTX, weil die
Dinger sind immer ausverkauft bei neuen Grafiker, immer, Leute wie waren denn die letzten Referenzkarten,
ging das von der Kühlung her, wobei ich glaube ich habe aktuell doch auch eine mit Referenzdesign,
also im Prinzip, ging, geht das voll klar, bei diesen Shops rechnen wir mit verfügbaren
Grafiker, na gut bei Amazon kannst du eigentlich immer mit rechnen, aber das wird gekauft direkt,
das wird direkt gekauft im Oktober, das ist bloß die Sache, wie sieht es denn mit der
neuen Ryzen Generation aus, gibt es da schon irgendwas, ne ne da sind ja nicht 5, 7, ne
wie heißt die neue Ryzen Generation denn dann, 9000, 7000, Ryzen kommt, haha, dann ist Ende
dieses Jahres wirklich mal Zeit für neuen Rechner, ok Ryzen, wie sieht denn so die Intel
Konkurrenz aktuell aus, wie viel RAM nutzt dein Browser, 8G oder so, Moment mal ich habe
noch mehr Tabs auf, das ist nicht das einzige, kann ich sagen wie viel RAM das braucht, guck
mal, nix quasi, naja, gut es sind mehrere Chromium Instanzen, weiß nicht ob man das
irgendwie gescheit zusammen rechnen kann, ist ein bisschen was ja, also insgesamt sind
gerade 8GB voll, RAM was aber auch daran liegt, dass ich meine VM nicht an habe, wer 2000
Euro für eine Grafikkarte ausgibt hat die Kontrollefälle, warum, wo ist das Problem,
aber das wird direkt zugeschlagen, gibt es zu den Ryzens schon irgendwelche Benchmarks
oder so, ich hab mich da überhaupt nicht zu informiert, ok also zeig mal her, ach haben
die wieder diesen Kram mit Verkaufsstart und Benchmark Embargo, ah die können mich mal
er, wobei die Dinger sind doch zum Release eh wieder nicht richtig lieferbar oder, kann's
doch eh wieder knicken, vielleicht kaufe ich dann besser Anfang Dezember irgendwann
oder so, wobei wenn ich Pech habe ist der Kram halt im Dezember halt nicht lieferbar,
weil dann alle für Weihnachten was kaufen, ok zeig mal her, was hat AMD dann hier zu
bieten, easy, sieht da kacke aus im Dark Reader, Ryzen 7000, zeichnen sich da schon irgendwas
ab, ob die Intel wieder komplett weg Gatschi bassen oder ob die da irgendwas entgegen zu
setzen haben, wo sieht man denn Chores und Taktraten und sowas, hier, nee, hä was juckt
mich das denn, also zeig mal her, ok das hat sich prinzipiell nicht viel geändert wahrscheinlich
hauptsächlich Taktraten und bisschen Architektur, Magic, weil ich glaube bisher war die Kernverteilung
schon genauso, also wahrscheinlich wird's wieder, der ist am Anfang eh nicht verfügbar,
die Dinger sind nie verfügbar am Anfang, also wird's eventuell dann der da, ich mein
sind immerhin doppelt so viele Kerne wie ich jetzt hab, ich hab jetzt ein, was ist das,
warte mal, Quad-Core, Octa-Core, was ist ein Sechsfachkerne, Hexa-Core, genau Hexa-Core,
chat ist einfach zu intelligent bei solchen Fragen, die wissen da Bescheid, Hexa-Core
und dann Zwölfer-Core, das heißt Zwölfer-Vlateinisch, das kann ich nicht aussprechen, ein was,
ein undezim, nee, Du-Dezim-Core, also das wär doch was oder Leute, das wär doch was,
ne 4090 und ne 7900X, Intel wird mehr Strom verbrauchen, ja wenn die Leistung stimmt,
juckt mich das nicht wenn es ein bisschen mehr Strom verbraucht, ich mein bei einer 4090
macht es das dann auch, da kann ich endlich mal wieder mein 800 Watt-Netzteil, was hier
im Schrank liegt, reinhauen, oh was sind das, Leute, Leute was ist das, ich seh da grad
was, guckt mal, Sekunde, was ist das, das neues Twitch-Feature, guckt mal, guckt mal,
was ist denn hier los, guckt euch das mal an, Boost in Process, also dank der Wubblos-Community,
Stream is now being recommended to new Viewers, Baum-KS, neue Leute, was mach ich denn da jetzt,
oh 96%, offline, meine normale Reaktion bei sowas ist natürlich offline gehen, ja, what
the, was ist das für ein neues Feature, eigentlich ist das richtig cool, wo ist eigentlich der
Sebaro wenn man ihn braucht, wo ist denn, wo ist denn der Cute-Mod, schon ewig nicht
gesehen, Moment, nicht 500 Viewer, 500 neue Viewer, Twitch-Interna-View-Bot, aber Leute,
das, da wird's, da wird im Oktober oder Anfang Dezember, wird der neue Rechner, boah, ey,
mein Auge, Baum-KS, kann man es doch nicht angucken, Flashbang, da wird neue Rechner
angebaut, würde ich sagen, was denn das, Alter, wenn diese Seiten nicht richtig scrollen,
für die RTX brauchst, achja, brauchen wir einen neuen Stecker, ein was, was für einen
Stecker, bitte schön, 12 Volt HPWR, was, ok, Power, 12 Volt, ein H, Power, was für
ein Teil, hm, das stimmt, das hat mein altes Netzteil nicht, kann man das nicht mit irgendeinem
Adapter machen, doch, bestimmt, oder, Adapter-Stell, Adapter-Champ, das passt schon, ah, passt
schon, ich hab nämlich noch ein richtig nice Sea-Sonic-Netzteil, hier, mit, glaub, 800
Watt oder sowas, Platinium-Rated, Leute, Sea-Sonic, 800, 500, Platinium-Rated, Prime, das klingt
gut, ich glaube, sowas, ja, ja, ich glaube, sowas hab ich noch hier, hab ich ja vor ein
paar Jahren gekauft für eine Kiste, die es nicht mehr gibt, und dann muss ich mir tatsächlich
mal für einen neuen Rechner kein neues Netzteil kaufen, kann ich das endlich mal benutzen,
gut, wahrscheinlich kaufen wir trotzdem ein neues Netzteil, aber das wird nice, ich hoffe,
ich hoffe wirklich, der Kram ist quasi zu bekommen, dann Ende des Jahres, also, dann
gibt's, ok, das wird teuer, das wird, was kosten, gibt es irgendwo News, was der Kram
kostet, Kostenwert, Preise, Preise im Überblick, ähm, hä, hier, also 550 Euro, es kostet
eh 600 Euro, der Kram ist eh immer teurer am Anfang, ok, das heißt, das wird teuer,
lass mal kurz grob überschlagen, Alter, das wird, das, ich muss mal, ich brauch was mit
Dark Mode, Alter, das wird, das wird ordentlich teuer, also 600 Euro CPU, 2000 Euro GPU, dann
bestimmt nochmal 250 Euro Netzteil, ähm, braucht man, braucht man der DDR5-Speicher,
da braucht, da braucht der DDR5-Speicher, ok, Moment, was kostet das aktuell, da muss
der, da muss das Ukraine-Sponsoring aber ordentlich reinhauen, ja, ich hab richtig Bock auf einen
Rechner wieder, wo ist denn hier der Filter von den Dudes, hier, DDR5 und ich muss, ja,
ich mach NordVPN-Sponsoring dann und Leute, aber ich brauch, ich brauch kein RGB, ja,
ich hab aktuell RGB-Rahmen einfach weil's geht, es ist komplett unsinnig, aber irgendwie,
glaub ich, hab ich das auch nur weil es damals lieferbar war und sonst nix, was, was nimmt,
war's nicht so, dass AMD ziemlich stark davon profitiert, wenn du schnellen RAM hast bzw.
niedrige RAM-Timings hast oder ist das nicht mehr so, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich immer
noch, oder? Kein RGB, Weirdchamp, na gut, gucken wir doch mal, was Corsair am Start hat,
RGB, Vengeance, RGB, RGB, ah, yes, das muss sein, na ja, mal Preis pro Gigabyte, das geht
doch eigentlich, 64G, das ist doch gar nicht mal so schlecht, 64G RAM 360 Euro, also, wie
gesagt, unter 64G mach ich das nicht, weil aktuell hab ich 32G, neuer Rechner muss immer
überall mehr haben, sonst, äh, tja, sonst nicht genug Schwanzverkleid, ich weiß nicht,
was sind denn, was sind denn gute Timings dabei, ich hab von DDR5 kein Plan, die sind
doch alle gleich, was kostet, ok, was kostet, was kostet der teuerste DDR5 RAM? Corsair
Dominator, CL4040, war das andere doch auch, ach, das ist ECC RAM, ach, hier, hier, ok,
36, 38, 38, 76, aber ist auch gar nicht so krass viel teurer, DDR5 ist immer ECC, wirklich,
warum, ist das so schnell getaktet, dass die quasi schon mit Fehlern rechnen, oder, oder
wie, ach, Moment, das ist die Hälfte, das ist, das ist quasi 32G, die kosten, die kosten
150 Euro mehr, 100 Euro mehr, ok, rechnen wir mal, rechnen wir mal ungefähr, die AMD
Seite, man, rechnen wir mal ungefähr mit 360, 360, äh, sagen wir 400, komm, wir rechnen
mit 400 Euro für, für RAM, Mainboard, gibt es, gibt es da schon welche für, was brauchen
die für nen Sockel, äh, gehen die noch mit den alten, AM5, ist AM5 ein neuer Sockel für
diese Ryzen Generation, oder gab es den schon mal, neu, neue E3 Version ist raus, und gibt
es irgendwas spannendes, ok, AM5 Mainboards, MSI nennt hohe Preise, na MSI kann mir eh
gestohlen bleiben, nachdem die mich gebannt haben auf Twitter, immer noch, immer noch,
von denen kaufe ich mir nix, cancels, ja, aber richtig, weg, ok, da muss man mal abwarten,
bis er jetzt noch rauskommt, Pricing, was, 480 Euro, seid ihr noch bei Trost für den
Mainboard, man, das ist aber wieder so ein unsinniges Asus Mainboard mit, äh, mit RGB
und irgendwie komischem Titanbeschlägen und, und Killer Fatality Headshot Pro Netzwerkkarten
und Gedöns, was keiner braucht, WiFi, wer braucht WiFi Onboard, useless, unsinnig, unsinnig,
ok, komm, ich rechne, ich, ich mach mal 450, so viel wird's wahrscheinlich am Ende nicht
mal sein, ok, was brauchen wir sonst noch Leute, ähm, der SSD, NVMe SSD, ich hätte
ja wirklich gerne ne 4TB, aber es gibt glaub ich keine sinnvolle 4TB NVMe, wir hatten
doch letztens geguckt, dann mach ich lieber, dann mach ich lieber ne 2TB rein, 2TB und
dann, äh, Gehäuse, Gehäuse kommt noch, ja, ja, Gehäuse, Noctua Lüfter, kommen dann
wieder, äh, nicht Noctua, Noctua, ich kann nicht mehr schreiben, Noctua, äh, CPU, Kühler,
keine Wasserkühlung, was soll es intern, Samsung 7, ja auf so eine wird's wahrscheinlich
dann auch rauslaufen, halt 2TB, ja, hoch, was jetzt, ja auf sowas wird's wahrscheinlich
dann rauslaufen, mein letztendlich, jetzt mal, jetzt mal ernsthaft, ja, ich kann da
auch ohne Probleme ne 2TB NVMe SSD reinstecken und mir dann noch von den übrigen Festplatten
hier noch was reinschieben, Gatschi Giga und dann noch irgendwie ne Zusatz SSD machen
für den Rest oder so, das passt schon, also, müssen wir ungefähr noch 230, sagen wir
so, 250 Euro für den SSD rechnen, den Rest hab ich also, anderweitig SSDs und Platten
und so hab ich, da brauch ich nix, ne, ich hab genug, ich hab genug, also SSDs hab ich
genug da und Platten hab ich genug da, ohne aufs Nass zu schieben, ich hab noch beispielsweise
ungenutzte, 2 ungenutzte 10TB Platten und ich hab noch unsinnigerweise paar 2TB SSDs,
das ist kein Ding, das ist kein Ding, nur NVMe SSDs hatte ich, hab ich keine mehr, so,
also Gehäuse, ich bin ja, Leute ihr müsst mir mal ein Gehäuse empfehlen, ich persönlich
bin ja ein riesen Fan der Fractal Design Dinger, wobei ich nicht weiß ob ich das für den neuen
Rechner auch mache, also, wahrscheinlich würde ich wieder das hier nehmen, meine letzten
3 Rechner Generationen hatten dieses Gehäuse hier, warum heißen die nicht mehr R, sondern
einfach so, ne, die hießen schon vorher nicht mehr R, doch die hießen noch R6 und das neun
R7, ich mein, ganz ehrlich Leute, wenn ich mit dem Gehäuse zufrieden bin, ja, und mich
nichts dran, macht doch eigentlich keinen Sinn, dass ich ein anderes Gehäuse nehme,
ich nehme einfach wieder das, was kostet denn der Kram aktuell, oh, Geizhals, ey, die werden
auch nicht billiger, ne, ich find's da halt gut, die haben einen Staubfilter vorne drinnen,
ansonsten sehr geräumisches Gehäuse, super stabil, halt ein bisschen groß, aber ok, was,
Strimmer plus, Moment, ne, das heißt wirklich Strimmer plus, SS-Strimmer plus, was, Moment,
ist das, ist das eine RGB-ATX-Verlängerung, seh ich das richtig, so ne, ATX-Stromverlängerung
mit RGB, wirklich ernst, ist das wirklich denen eher ernst, ja, mir fehlen die Worte
dafür, ich weiß, was soll ich denn dazu sagen, genau, was ist die Existenzberechtigung dieses
Stückes Hardware, was, hä, warum ist das, warum existiert das überhaupt, warum ist
das der Strimmer oder der S-Strimmer oder der Streamer plus, ok, das muss wir uns mal
kurz in Action angucken, in Action, wir haben erstmal den Player geprickt auf der Seite durch
Fullscreen, guck, der resized nicht, kein, kein responsive Webdesign hier, ich hab, ich
bin wirklich sehr irritiert, kann man da glaube ich gut zu sagen, Moment, ich hab, das heißt,
ich bräuchte jetzt noch ne dritte und vierte RGB-Software, das heißt, ich brauch drei
verschiedene Software um dann von meinem Mainboard, von meinem ATX, man muss sich das, man muss
sich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, Leute, es gibt eine extra Software, also wir
sind im Jahr fast 2023, es gibt eine extra Software, mit dem ich die RGB-Settings meines
ATX-Verlängerungskabels einstellen kann, das hört sich einfach nicht normal an, also
nicht schon schlimm genug, dass es ein ATX-Verlängerungskabel mit RGB gibt, aber nein, es gibt eine Windows-Software
um das steuern zu können, darf ich nicht zu lange angucken, sonst kauf ich mir das noch,
smooth lightning style, Leute, ich mach einfach den 5-Hat-Case-Modder-Move, ich häng mir
einfach einen Micro-Controller mit WLED in den Rechner und mach zwei 144 LED-Aufmeter
RGB-Strips rein, dann hab ich die beste Steuerung für LEDs und die wahrscheinlich besten RGB-LEDs,
ich mein, das ist jetzt zwar keine SATA-Verlängerung und ich weiß nicht, was ich damit im Rechner
machen soll, aber ich könnte es machen, eine WLED in den Rechner reinhauen, ok, sagen
wir mal 250 Euro noch mal fürs Gehäuse, Case, man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts, was fehlt
mir denn jetzt noch, hab ich was vergessen, noch die Noctur-Lüfter, was haben die aktuell,
da gibt's doch bestimmt was für, please refer to our socket compatibility overview, in short,
Noctur-School-Amornigates-Support-AM4-Upwards-Kompatibel-AM5, ok, Noctur-AMD-Lüfter, den hab ich aktuell,
den würd ich dann tatsächlich, Moment, was, die Farben irritieren mich, was, was ist was,
was ist, achso, wenn man eine ältere Version hat, dann passt das nicht, achja, gut, gut,
nee, nee, passt schon, passt schon, also den hab ich aktuell, der ist doch wahrscheinlich
immer noch so mit der beste Lüfter, den's gibt, oder, vermute ich mal, von denen, so
einen hab ich aktuell drauf, dann würd ich einfach wieder einkaufen, wobei, ich hab nur,
ich hab die Variante nur mit einem, nur mit einem, ich hab den da, glaub ich, der hat
nur, der hat nur einen Lüfter oben drauf, ach nee, das ist die Silent-Version, warum
kein Custom-Water-Cooling, weil ich nicht so scharf auf Wasserkühlung bin.
So, also, sagen wir mal, ungefähr 100 Euro nochmal Lüfter, Lüfter, okay, hab ich was
vergessen, hab ich irgendwas vergessen, CPU, GPU, Netzwerkkarte hab ich noch, 10G-Netzwerkkarte
hab ich hier noch, brauch ich nicht kaufen, ähm, was, hab ich was vergessen, CPU, also
Prozessor, Grafikkarte, Netzteil, RAM, Mainboards, SSD, Gehäuse und Lüfter, nee, Gehäuse, Lüfter
brauch ich nicht, außerdem hat das, hat das Fractal Design schon welche dabei, die sind
auf niedrigsten Stufen absolut in Ordnung, ähm, DVD-Laufwerk, brauch ich nicht, hätt'
ich zur Not auch noch, war's eigentlich, oder?
Okay, zeig mal her, was kostet der Spaß, 600 plus 2000 plus 250 plus 400 plus 450 plus
250 plus 250 plus 100, eieieieiei, das, ich mein, das ist quasi, das ist ungefähr, Moment
Leute, lass mich mal kurz ausrechnen, ja, das ist ungefähr ein Sechstel von dem, was
mein Auto gekostet hat, oder, hab ich das richtig ausgerechnet, also, sag mal, das Sechsfache,
nee, schwachsinnig, ein Sechstel, nee, blödsinnig, das Sechsfache davon, ja, das ist ungefähr
das Sechszweit, 25.200 Euro hat das Auto gekostet, das heißt, ich kauf mir jetzt einen Rechner,
ungefähr so, naja, warum nicht, warum nicht, kann man doch mal machen, aber 4300 Euro für
den Rechner ist schon ne Hausnummer, ja, was für Teile, das ist in Ryzen, wenn ich das
alles bekomme, 900x, das ist ne 4000 Euro, ja, Netzteil, Restzeug, ja, wofür brauchst
du so viel RAM, ganz einfach, nach 32 GB RAM kommt 64 GB RAM, und 32 GB RAM hab ich grad
aktuell im Rechner, das heißt, die logische Konsequenz ist, dass ich jetzt 64 GB RAM
hole.
Sowas wie 48 GB RAM kommt mir nicht in die Tüte, immer hoch 2, wisst ihr doch, 2, 4,
8, 16, 32, 64, 128, 256, 512.024, 2048, 4096, weiter komm ich nicht, Leute, 8192, glaub
ich, aber, und danach hört's bei mir auf, ja, das heißt, logischerweise, nach 32 GB
RAM kommt rechnerisch gesehen 64 GB RAM, und es muss mehr sein.
Du lastest doch never 64 GB aus, naja, ich mein, ich schaff's immerhin schon mal 18 GB
auszulasten mit 32 GB RAM, und wenn ich noch ein paar Tabs aufmache und neue Browser Windows,
dann schaff ich's auf 64 GB RAM auszulasten.
Ja, so sieht's aus, euer Rechner wird dann Ende des Jahr, also, vorausgesetzt, gibt ordentliche
Hardware, die erwerbbar ist, und die dann nicht viel, viel mehr kostet.
Welche CPU hast du jetzt?
Aktuell hab ich einen Tau..
Ach, Grafika, das, sorry.
Einen 8700 K hab ich.
Bisschen übertaktet, wobei, nein, das stimmt nicht, übertaktet hab ich ihn gar nicht mehr,
ich hab nur Multicore Enhancement an, also, sprich, dass alle CPU Kerne auf maximalen
gehen top was was sind der maximale takt 4,7 gigahertz glaube ich bei dem 8700k also aktuell
habe ich in 8700k 1080ti der rechner war absolut top high-end zur damaligen zeit aber das
ist halt fünf jahre her man muss sich mal überlegen ich komme immer noch nicht drauf
klar dass ich mir jetzt quasi erst fünf jahre später einen neuen rechner kaufen muss muss
kaufen werde wenn das wenn der plan so eintritt man muss halt dazu sagen leistungstechnik
bräuchte ich das überhaupt noch nicht der 8700k und die 1080ti sind komplett ausreichend
es gibt nichts was ich nicht spielen kann und ich kann die meisten sachen sogar ohne
probleme in richtig also in höchsten details spielen jetzt vielleicht nicht die ultra optionen
überall angehakt aber in hohen settings und sehr hohen settings überall ich stelle sogar
lieber ein bisschen runter weil ich halt lieber 100 fps habe als 40 50 und dafür ein bisschen
bessere quali mache ich dann alles nach ne doch also serious max das mache ich dann falls
ich heizen muss mit meinem neuen rechner wie viel habe ich ausgerechnet keckel keckels
kostet das 4300 keckels das ist doch das ist schon ordentlich also muss man muss man sagen
das ist ordentlich aber ganz im ernst ich gebe sonst nie geld aus ok ich gebe zu das
wirkt jetzt ein bisschen doof wenn ich mir erst vor drei wochen auto gekauft aber normalerweise
gebe ich nie geld aus generell die einfachste variante bisschen geld zu haben ist ja mehr
geld zu behalten als auszugeben und das habe ich ja prinzipiell die letzten jahre über
eigentlich gemacht ich habe eigentlich immer mehr geld behalten als ausgegeben beziehungsweise
also mittlerweile auch das ein oder andere in meinen in meinen etf plan aber ansonsten
gönnt sich doch sonst ich meine guckte mal für was gehe ich dann arbeiten für was mache
ich youtube für was mache ich twitch für was mache ich sellout mit ukraine und nord
vpn und ubisoft und ei zu spiel dich nicht mag wenn man sich denn nicht mal einen rechner
für kaufen kann also das muss das muss sein das muss sein
rechtfertigst du das für meinen bankkonto also ich glaube das kann man das das geht
schon mal da machen wir wieder ein video zu vielleicht vielleicht chat seit ich ich habe
hier angefangen zu streamen quasi erst nachdem ich meinen letzten rechner gebaut habe also
so lang ist bin ich ja noch gar nicht hier also ich bin ich bin kürzer auf twitch als
ich mein rechner gekauft letzten rechner gebaut habe das heißt vielleicht bauen wir den sogar
im stream zusammen da weiß ich aber noch nicht wie ich das gescheit mache rechner und rechner
nee rechner und rechner ist bescheuert also mein rechner stellt den stelle ich hier
nebenan schreibt ich wie die anderen zwei die da gerade da stehen ich muss dann halt
den einen rechner den ich jetzt hier als vorschau rechner habe quasi auf den dachboden bringen
ich weiß ja sachen irgendwie nicht weg und den den ich jetzt benutze als main rechner
kommt dann als vorschau streaming rechner links daneben ich rotiere das immer so durch
so siehts aus
hier doch hier sind doch viele leute die sich mit smart home auskennen ich suche raumtemperatur
plus feuchtigkeitssensor mit display und offener wlan api hatte jemand zufällig welche zu
empfehlen ja aber nur bist du überhaupt noch da nicht dass ich jetzt was beantworte was
eigentlich schon vor halben stunde wart mal timestamps wo kann man timestamp konnte man
nicht mit chat appearance hier also wie das einfach mal 40 minuten her ist alter ja ich
kann dir was empfehlen was was ziemlich nice sogar was auch sehr günstig ist du musst
allerdings dafür ein bisschen selber basteln kann ich aber aus eigener erfahrung empfehlen
habe ich selbst im gesamten haus ich habe mittlerweile glaube ich sieben stück oder
so davon und zwar die hier die dinger du musst mal gucken die gibt es teilweise für acht
oder ich habe sie damals bei aliexpress für unter acht euro das stück gekriegt wie heißen
die dinger eigentlich wie heißt die dinger dann offiziell egal
hier ist zum flaschen muss das ich muss das richtige richtige repo raussuchen hier das
da also wenn man muss erst mal gucken ob die noch flashbar sind so also ich habe davon
sieben stück aktuell das ist echt nicht wie die dinger heiß nach was ich da suchen muss
ja nach nach diesen guck mal 4 9 90 alter auf gehts das ist das ist scam oder ach firmen
sitzt in spanien mann was ist das kann ich traue ich mich da überhaupt drauf zu klicken
eher nicht ja guck mal du guck mal du findest barberry base 8 euro 80 wunderbar also davon
kannst du dir bestellte dir einfach mal ein fünfer pack so du musst noch gucken dass
es die version ist die flashbar ist und dann kannst du im archiv gucken archiv wo blorz
da haben wir nämlich mal homos ist entheizung thermostat ne wir haben die dinger geflasht
im stream rgb plus noch mehr sachen flaschen mehr china geräte flaschen muss mal gucken
wir haben die wir haben die sachen zusammen im stream geflasht da oben liegt da oben
liegt doch oder das ist doch das ist doch das stream am leak da ja ich glaube das ist
das stream was geflasht haben ob war das das stream nicht gelöscht hat weil ich weil ich
kann muss es nee das war nicht dass die mich gelöscht hat weil ich zwischendurch aufs
klo muss also im stream haben wir das ganze geflasht zusammen also was du machen kannst
ist du kaufst dir von den dingern welche und dann flasht du die mit dieser custom firmware
hier oder alternativ auch mit der originalen übrigens leute soll ich euch mal was sagen
nur dass man nur dass jetzt keiner mal kommt sagt hier ich würde immer das zeug nutzen
und nichts kontributen ich habe den erst dem ersteller der firmware damals drei geräte
kostenlos zugeschickt per post inklusive versand den ich übernommen habe zum ausprobieren
zum verbessern der firmware dass neuere versionen unterstützt werden können ich gebe zu nicht
ganz uneigen nützlich weil ich meine ich wollte ja dass das neue display unterstützt
wird so und wenn du das gemacht hast wenn du die dinger geflasht hast dann hast du ein
thermostat oder thermometer thermometer mit luftfeuchtigkeit temperatur und wenn du in den settings also
du kannst da richtig du kannst da richtig viel einstellen drauf nach dem flaschen mit
custom firmware und dann musst du den intervall runter stellen weil diese dinger sind standardmäßig
total pepega eingestellt die schicken standardmäßig irgendwie alle zehn sekunden oder so ihre
werte wenn du das runter stellst auf 15 minuten oder zehn minuten weil ich mein wie oft willst
du die temperatur update haben ja dazu gucken wir uns gleich ein video an wenn du die dann
einstellst dass die nur noch alle zehn oder 15 minuten ihre temperatur reporten das hält
ewig das zeug das hält ewig ich guck mal kurz grad mal nach bei amazon wann ich mein
erstes bestellt habe also ich guck mal kurz nach in der app bei amazon wann ich das erste
bestellt habe und es ist es ist bei 56 prozent batteriestand das hält länger als ein jahr
mi so ich schau mal nach mi hier hier ist die waage nee moment das muss ich jetzt mal
kurz raussuchen ok ich habe das erste thermostat bestellt ja das erste thermostat bestellt
habe ich 5 april lasst euch das mal 5 april 2021 und die batterie ist jetzt bei 56 prozent
das heißt die batterie wird ungefähr drei jahre halten da kannst du dich nicht beschweren
oder so was du dazu brauchst ist ein raspberry pi und dann musst du custom firmware drauf
flaschen diese dinger du willst das ganze über wifi machen aber du willst das nicht
über wifi machen weil wifi beschissene oh sorry heute sehr netter stream weil wifi unschärfen
dem energieverbrauch aufweist was geräte mit batterie angeht du willst kein wifi du
willst entweder da ist da ist eine ganz normale cr cr irgendwas knopfzelle drin die dinger
sind auch wirklich klein und leicht c s cr c s so eine ganz kleine knopfzelle ist da
drin so also was man nämlich haben will für wireless kommunikation mit batterie ist das
erste kein wlan und das zweite auch schon mal kein wlan so das nächste zwar diese technologie
die du haben willst sie sind entweder zig b seawave deckt laura oder bluetooth low energy
und die dinger hier sind low energy ja ob threat und meta überhaupt irgendwie mal was
wird mir mal gespannt geht ja angeblich jetzt mal los so das ist das was man haben will
und das ist low energy bluetooth das heißt du brauchst einen bluetooth empfänger dafür
halten die batterien lang und es reicht ein ordentlich platziert empfänger ich habe auch
nur einen empfänger im haus der hängt bei mir oben im bad der empfänger neben der waage
du brauchst einen bluetooth empfänger der das dann an deiner heim automatisierung weiter
weiter schickt das war es und dann hast du billiger wie alles andere super funktionsfähige
und uns ewighaltende thermometer und luftfeuchtigkeit sensoren das ist doch was oder meinst du kriegst
das hin mit dem flaschen du kannst dir mal ein stream angucken also das flaschen ist
nicht schwierig du brauchst ein raspberry pi du brauchst die firmware und du brauchst
die webseite von denen wo du dann den assistent durchklickst gut wenn du kein raspberry pi
hast es natürlich schwierig da aktuell einzukriegen ist nicht wird macht nichts vergiss war sich
gesagt hat du brauchst kein raspberry pi das ist blödsinnig mit raspberry pi hat es
glaube ich damals gar nicht richtig funktioniert ich habe das mit dem bluetooth stick über
mein desktop rechner gemacht damals sogar das flaschen aber raspberry pi müsste eigentlich
prinzipiell auch gehen du kannst den raspberry pi als empfänger verwenden wobei ich ich
habe den esp 32 im bad so ihr könnt auch die neuen bluetooth proxys von home assistant
verwenden also das das kann ich dir wirklich empfehlen wie gesagt mittlerweile sieben dinger
und die halten ewig lang haben super funktionen lassen sich jetzt seit dem letzten home assistant
upgrade noch einfacher integrieren und ist eigentlich eine super geschichte ich meine
wenn es dir auf wirklich nach komma stellen super genauigkeit ankommt weil du irgendwie
dein terrarium danach anstellen willst und deine käfer und und schlangen sonst den löffel
abgeben da drinnen wenn es halbes grad zu warm ist dann würde ich die dinger nicht
nehmen ja und in hoher luftfeuchtigkeit würde ich die wahrscheinlich auch nicht auf dauer
einsetzen aber so um sie in der wohnung zu verteilen dass du einfach weißt ob es in
deinem raum jetzt 25 26 oder nur 18 grad warm ist sind die dinger perfekt ja ja dann dann
nehmen die kann ich nur viel guck aber vorher mal nach also ich habe meine vor über einem
jahr geflasht guck mal vorher nach auf github und so ob diese revisionen die es aktuell
zu kaufen gibt flashbar sind oder bestellt ihr mal eins ich meine 8 euro kann man ausgeben
und guck ob das noch geht wenn es nämlich nicht mal geht dann ist dann ist es hinfällig
was ich gesagt habe ich brauche übrigens auch was neues hat da hat vielleicht jemand von
euch ein tipp ich brauche ein ein temperatursensor für den fischteich im garten ich hatte die
ganze zeit folgendes da dran fkg 100 fibaro nicht die baro viel nehmen wir jetzt das ding
fibaro fkg 100 oder so ich hatte die ganze zeit so einen seawave sensor der allerdings
zusätzlich die möglichkeit hat ein ds 18b 20 temperatursensor anzuschließen also ich
hatte quasi einen seawave sensor mit mit so einem wasserdichten wasserdichten probe für
den fischteich so hatte ich das die ganze zeit im garten liegen aber das ding ist mir
einmal nass geworden weil ich zu blöd war es einzupacken und seitdem hat es probleme
ich habe seitdem in wasserdichtes gehäuse und so passt auch alles aber dass das macht
probleme und ich glaube jetzt ist es endgültig verreckt weil seit zwei drei wochen liefert
es gar keine werte mehr und hat jemand eine idee für den temperatursensor für den fischteich
das muss auch nicht zwangsläufig auch outdoor fähig sein also ich habe auch keine probleme
mit den empfänger eine wasserdichte box noch mal zusätzlich zu packen oder so ist halt
nur die sache wenn es wifi ist was beschissen ist weil was unschärfer aufweist was blöd
ist mit wifi weil die verbrauchen zu viel energie und es muss wireless sein also was
ich mir auch schon überlegt habe vielleicht irgendein sensor vielleicht mit bluetooth
oder so und dann mache ich ein bluetooth proxy in den stall zu meinem home assistant ins
haus aber kennt da jemand kennt da ja mit ja mit low energy bluetooth würde auch funktionieren
die schauen mir dinge in den zippern das bringt nichts das die messen doch überhaupt nicht
richtig ne ne ne ne das ist das ist blödsinnig die probe muss ins wasser der die sendeinheit
die muss schon über überirdisch bleiben doch doch so werde ich das wahrscheinlich auch
hand haben der sensor kommt ins war ja kommt auch an wie das gebaut ist der sensor kommt
ins wasser und der rest kommt in eine wasserdichte box wasserdichte box habe ich ja da ist ja
der aktuelle sensor schon drin nur dass der einmal in wasserschaden hat und sich nie wieder
davon erfolgt hat will ich beim beim neuen sensor vermeiden ja also low energy bluetooth
werden wir wahrscheinlich am liebsten weil da könnte ich den relay in stahl stöpseln
mit dem esp 32 und könnte die daten empfangen also falls da jemand irgendwie guten tipp für
hat mich echt interessieren cool thermometer punkt eu 29 euro geht ja sogar display brauche
ich kein display display braucht unnütz viel batterie inkbird ok wir kommen einfach mal
bei amazon inkbird wasser term inkbird inkbird thermometer der hast du eine super mario playlist
ist keine sunshine playlist nur eine playlist sowas moment mein ich habe eine wasserdichte
box ich brauche keine box ich brauche das thermometer hygrometer was auch immer ich brauche
kein hygrometer ich brauche ein thermometer kann dann home assistant inkbird achja guck
mal da die haben sogar eine offizielle integration ja das ist pogg bluetooth thermometer ibs th
1 geiler name weißt du sofort also leute wenn ihr bei ibs th 1 nicht so ver nicht sofort
an den thermometer denkt ja dann weiß ich auch nicht da weißt du weißt du sofort bescheid
wenn du das hast wenn du den namen wenn du den namen liest alles klar gibt es das nicht
zu kaufen grad gibt es das gar nicht zu kaufen da ist es doch die amazon die amazon suche
ist schon ziemlich ziemlich verbesserungswürdig oder oder habe ich bloß nicht gefunden schon
mal über treestyle tabs nachgeguckt ja und wieder uninstalled es war das erste ergebnis
wirklich 29 euro geht doch eigentlich auch klar so und das ist bluetooth ja es gibt eine
offizielle home assistant integration ja was will ich mehr das ist doch eigentlich richtig
gut das das nehmen wir einfach beim eto basket die hälfte davon habe ich schon bestellt jetzt
wo ich sehe so ein teil wollte ich mir auch noch bestellen ok ja da haben wir doch schon
was probiere ich mal aus mal gucken wie das ist also ich muss ja dann in meinen fischteich
die den sensor also der sensor kommt in fischteich so mal kurz überlegen also diese probe hier
der sensor kommt in fischteich gibt es da nicht irgendwie gescheite bilder von anstatt
hier bei amazon video bilder bilder sind alle ziemlich crap video fische halten in 2022
warum nicht unboxing weißt du was mit dem teich passiert chain law wenn da keine fische
drin sind der ist innerhalb von einem halben jahr komplett zu mit algen und und zeug und
sonst was und ist komplett für den arsch das einzige was du machen könnt ist es komplett
leer alles alles rauskratzen alles weg machen und halt ohne wasser aber da hast du ein loch
im garten am moment jetzt ist das mit ok egal ignorieren wir mal dass das den display hat
also die probe kommt die probe kommt hier nebendran das könnt ihr jetzt noch mal zeigen
oder ja auf ich kann ich mag diese videos ich kann es ich kann es nicht ab könnt ihr
das nicht einfach mal normal zeigen please nö haben wir keinen bock drauf hier hier
ok also das kommt da dran und der rest geht per bluetooth ok easy easy ich würde sagen
das bestelle ich mal und dann gucken wir ob das ob das funktioniert mit bluetooth low
energy ja ich will kein display bloß nicht display ist die pest hier das braucht einfach
eine unnützbatterie ich meine ich brauche ja kein display das ding liegt im garten
in der wasserdichten kiste ihr dankeschön für die subs leute ich habe euch zwar schon
von der halben stunde gesehen aber ich bin so lahm mit meinem chat dankeschön poc subscription
die fauners edition war nicht das referenzdesign sondern das faunersdesign wo willst du die
temp eigentlich ausgeben ich will die in meiner heimautomatisierung drin haben da pack
ich mir dann ins dashboard und setze eine warnung drauf dass wenn das unter 5 grad
fällt dass ich den teich abdecken gehen muss dass es nicht zugefriert und die ja wie
die beschichtung beschichtung und becken kaputt geht und außerdem muss ich das zudecken
wenn das zu sehr gefriert das ist für die fische fische ja auch nicht gut die geben
dann da drinnen da hat sich ausgefischt dann das bringt nichts das geht nicht warte mal
leute ich scroll mal kurz im chat runter dankeschön niklas für den sub sorry falls ich irgendjemand
übersehen habe alle subs richtig poc heute messen messes subscribers die power netzteil
so hier sind wir beim rechner kaufen mich interessiert kein sweet spot beim rechner
ich will progas leistung preis ist nicht so wichtig moin tommy lang nicht gesehen so
ich glaube jetzt habe ich den chat gleich durch
vor ok also was habe heute von einem mit kollegen die seite bock wie da kam an virtuell
respiratory pies mit sensoren und so weiter bestücken die seite ist sehr praktisch falls
jemand was für ein ding bock wie online arduino und esp 32 simulator war das nice hab ich
bis jetzt noch nicht gebraucht ich habe noch genug geräte hier so also das funktioniert
nicht und warum funktioniert das nicht wegen dem was ich glaube ich heute schon fünf mal
erzählt habe weil wlan kacke ist für batteriebetriebene geräte und esp 32 wenn du nicht ein ganz spezielles
oder eines der wenigen ganz speziellen boards nimmst die im deep sleep nahezu nichts verbrauchen
ist ein esp 32 auch eine kack plattform für einen kabellosen sensor und man davon abgesehen
noch mehr als genug von diesen sensoren von diesen sensoren da aber der esp 32 ist keine
gute plattform dafür dazu kommt dass ich keinen wlan empfang oder schlechten wlan empfang
an der stelle habe wieso ist wlan kacke weil wlan viel energieverbrauch beim übertragen
ich meine klar wenn du die wenn du die übertragung runterschraubst auf einmal am tag oder so
dann geht das mit wlan auch aber in der regel sind halt diese geräte wo wlan mit drauf
ist auch schon nicht sonderlich energiesprachen ich meine raspberry pie müssen wir gar nicht
von reden raspberry pie könnte nicht gescheit mit batterie betreiben deswegen verbraucht
viel zu viel hat kein deep sleep und nix kannst du knicken nehmen esp 32 esp 32 verbrauch zwar
im vergleich zu so normaler hardware die man sonst so hat fast nix aber in esp 32 verbraucht
ungefähr 180 milliampere wenn wlan aktiv ist und irgendwie keine ahnung 70 80 milliampere
oder so wenn er einfach am start ist mit bluetooth wird er dann wahrscheinlich 100 milliampere
verbrauchen aber ja so in dem dreh es machts machts nicht fett das eigentliche problem
beim esp 32 ist beziehungsweise auch beim esp 82 66 ist die controller es geht um so
ein ding ich zeig ich zeig ich zeig mal eins für die die sich jetzt da nichts darunter
vorstellen können es geht um solche kleinen controller hier das problem beim esp 32 und
solche controller ist du kannst das modul zwar in deep sleep schicken und im deep sleep
verbraucht also nennen wir es mal stand by deep sleep ist da korrekte wort für im deep
sleep verbraucht die eigentliche der eigentliche controller so gut wie nix mehr aber die boards
sind alle nicht dafür ausgelegt die haben beispielsweise in usb spannungswandler drauf oder led drauf
oder sonstige geschichten die beim deep sleep nicht richtig ausgehen das heißt es gibt nur
ganz wenige boards die wirklich energiesparend ausgelegt sind zum beispiel gibt es hier ein
habe ich sogar noch ein board da gibt es die die verbrauchen irgendwie nur paar paar micro
ampere im deep sleep und das kannst du dann wenn du es vielleicht am tag eins zweimal
aufwächst misst verschickst und wieder die lieb geht kannst du es vielleicht ordentlich
betreiben allerdings muss es dann auch sagen wir mal 1200 milliampere stunden akku sein
weil ansonsten hält auch das nicht lang also man sieht schon es ist nicht einfach in esp
30 sensor wireless zu betreiben wenn es auch eine weile halten soll ja wenn wenn damit
keine probleme hast das nach ein paar wochen das strom alle ist dann ist kein problem also
wenn man nachts an einem akku pack ein raushängen willst oder so das ist auch kein problem aber
wenn du willst dass das ding 1 2 3 jahre da autark mit batterie daten sendet ist in esp
32 meistens oder so out of the box zumindest keine gute wahl ja siehst du da machst man
macht es einfach noch komplizierter dann musste dann musste noch ein solar panel da hinlegen
dann musste da noch eine lade elektronik für die batterie rein packen dann musste noch
irgendwelche spannungswandler und regler rein machen dass du das ding nicht grillst und
dann hast du dann hast du ein ziemlich umfangreiches großes teil neben deinem teich liegen zumal
du ja das solar panel meistens auch nicht dorthin machen kannst wo der teich ist sondern
wahrscheinlich auf den busch obendrauf machen musst oder so also da ist es deutlich besser
man kauft sich irgendeinen bluetooth low energy ding und proxied das irgendwie weiter anstatt
sich selbst was mit esp zu bauen ja aber wie gesagt selbst mit dem akku funktioniert
jetzt ja nicht gescheit habe ich doch gerade gesagt selbst wenn du den akku rein machst
und so 1200 milliampere akku ist so also so dass du kriegst du noch ganz gut in kleiner
form ja in so einem kleinen akku pack selbst damit hält das moment ich zeig es euch mal
ich habe leider vergessen hier der calculator ist nicht so geil aber ok also guck mal consumption
during code execution sagen wir mal 100 milliampere braucht das ding consumption in deep sleep
wo hier sind milliampere hier sind microampere so und der fire beetle esp 32 der brauche
im stand by deep sleep diese seite man sieht ja beschissen aus sleep 10 microampere realistisch
betrachtet ist ein bisschen mehr ja so duration of code execution naja 2 sekunden ist gar
nicht mal so verkehrt ich meine das ding muss aufwachen das muss eine messung vornehmen
und es muss sich ins wi-fi einlocken und im wi-fi den kram verschicken wenn wir es jetzt
mal mit wlan machen wir nehmen 1200 milliampere stundenbatterie ja was weiß ich 20 prozent
discharge das ist in ordnung so oh misst oh gott ich nur beider näher hat sich näher
hat sich nicht gemerkt doch hat sich hat sich gemerkt recht jetzt so sleep time sleep time
ist nicht 120 sleep time ist also guckt mal hier sieht man es doch ganz gut wenn ich wenn
ich das ding nur alle zwei minuten aufwecke dann hält das gerade mal gerade mal 24 tage
der esp 32 h2 ist das schon lieferbar das wäre natürlich nice wobei dir das ja nichts
bringt wenn das ding kann wenn das ding nicht deutlich strom sparen da ist so sleep time
ist also das ist natürlich deutlich zu kurz sagen wir mal sagen wir mal so sagen wir mal
einmal am tag da sieht das ganze natürlich schon anders aus ach moment doch es erscheint
mir ein bisschen viel oder dann sieht das ganze schon ein bisschen anders aus aber das
ist jetzt auch eher eher unrealistisch weil die batterie entlädt sich auch das aber irgendwie
so also dann wird es auch rechnerisch quasi jetzt zwar zwei jahre halten aber da sieht
man schon allein schon dass das keine ahnung also allein schon also man muss schon wirklich
hier hoch gehen mit mit der die mit der deep sleep zeit dass das ein zwei jahre hält wobei
das auch nur am rand realistisch die batterie entlädt sich und du brauchst dir allein schon
dass das funktioniert genau es sind wahrscheinlich sogar eher vier in dem fall aber sagen wir
mal kriegt es durchaus hin mit einem jahr batterie laufzeit aber das ist auch 1200 milliampere
stunden batterie also da ist schon da ist schon einiges drin so eine normale kleine
knopfzelle 240 oder sowas also und dass du das leckt oder was leckt leckt nix und dass
du das machen kannst brauchst du das richtige sp 32 board nicht irgendeins wirklich genau
das genau die richtigen richtige law power board du musst das wirklich recht freifertig
programmieren dass das alles funktioniert du brauchst ein akku und du musst das so konstruieren
dass es alles klar also ganz im ernst ein autark laufendes sp 32 gerät mit einem sensor
ich glaube ihr seht jetzt das ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne gibt es aber überhaupt lieferbar
alter nee gibt es gar nicht lieferbar oder kann man sich kaufen mal bei aliexpress gucken
schiller chinesen shop die haben noch bestimmt sowas wenn du den kram noch nicht mal noch
nicht mal bei den chinesen kaufen kannst dann kannst du es aktuell klicken zu bekommen
ob kannst du kannst vergessen also seht ihr es ist keine so gute idee er angeblich dass
er sich beintegriert hat wie gesagt bringt es aber auch nicht wenn ich wenn die wenn
er stand by verbraucht weiterhin so auf den meisten boards es ist auch in 1200 milliampere
stunden akku drinnen eine powerbank hat noch ein bisschen mehr meistens aber du musst
es ja irgendwie auch in die wasserdichte box reinkriegen doch kann man aber habe ich gerade
erklärt geht auch nicht so einfach wenn du eine wenn du da ein solar panel anschließen
willst du brauchst irgendeinen regler du brauchst in der lade elektronik du brauchst
irgendwie dass das ding nicht gegrillt wird wenn man zu sehr die sonne drauf scheint also
dann hast du ein relativ umfangreiches projekt und vor allem eins was du nicht so einfach
mal nebenbei an teich legst dass das fällt dann schon auf dass das da liegt also in dem
fall fährt man tatsächlich mit einer lupe mit der plo lupe bluetooth low energy variante
und einer batterie die man alle zwei jahre erneuert wahrscheinlich deutlich besser also
ihr seht das ist gar nicht so einfach wie das auf den ersten blick aussieht so was
zu bauen übrigens war es zu konstruieren glaubst du du wirst mit einer zukunft den
400 series grafiken von der keine ahnung mal gucken mal gucken mal schauen erst mal muss
ich den kram bekommen und erst mal muss ich den kram bekommen dann muss die cpu auch
lieferbar sein und mal gucken ob das was wird mit ende des jahres ich bin gespannt also
es immer schwierig neue hardware zu release zu bekommen ne die performance ist nicht
besser als unter feieres dafür habe ich keine gängelungen mehr von feieres und komplette
kontrolle übers tablet was praktisch für mich ist weil ich ja eben als dashboard an der
wand verwenden will aber ja das läuft jetzt unter android das liegt aber noch neben mir
das ist noch nicht an der wand so jetzt aus sondern wir haben noch 20 minuten zeit wir
gucken uns auch ein paar videos an lass mal schauen was haben wir denn hier quick the
world's first javascript framework na dann was soll das im kontext von javascript framework
eigentlich bedeuten weil normalerweise ist das laufzeit ist das eine laufzeit angabe aber
was soll das was soll das bei dem javascript framework überhaupt bedeuten blazingly fast
mitten in rust ja wahrscheinlich so hören wir uns das mal an also auf gibt's was was
gibt's ja moment kam nicht letztens was raus was so ähnlich hieß und so ein gelbes logo
hatte was war das noch mal mit dem gelben logo letztens das hieß doch auch so ähnlich
wenn ich hatte tp3 quick so was mit dem gelben logo war das frech frech war das letzte genau
frech framework ist frech framework github das war kann ich mich noch dran erinnern next
gen web framework also es ist wirklich gut das ist jetzt ein präsent server side geschichte
ich heiße gut level cap gbade aber die sind wirklich außer rand und band die javascript
leute was neue frameworks angeht wait a minute was blazingly fast ja ja ok ok das video ist
anscheinend nur in 480p wir wissen nicht genau warum aber wahrscheinlich youtube hat die
verarbeitung verkackt it's time to reset the counter also quick erzähl fire ship javascript
framework has been released the highly anticipated quick framework built by a dream team of
developers just hit beta yesterday now before you go and change the channel this isn't just
another that is also that is also gleich sein code ja it brings an entirely new rendering
paradigm to the table called resume ability which totally eliminates the need for hydration
the technique used by almost every metaframe work today to make server render websites
also nur für die für alle denen das nix sagt ich sag das immer so vorwurfsvoll oder heute
ist netter stream ich mein das überhaupt nicht so das ist für alle die das nix sagt
so nach dem motto für alle die so dumm sind und hab es nicht gehört bisher so meine ich
das gar nicht ich erkläre ab und zu mal ganz gerne sachen eben gerade falls jemand was
noch nicht gehört hat also was mit hydration gemeint ist das folgendes wenn du eine webseite
auslieferst mit interaktiven elementen also irgendwas was mit javascript läuft dann im
browser ja das kann irgendwie den counter sein irgendwie den ticker oder was auch immer
irgendwie was oder hier nachladende kommentare oder solche geschichten also irgendwas was
interaktiv ist ja da läuft das mit javascript im browser so die letzten paar jahre hat man
es eher so gemacht dass man die webseite ausliefert an euch also an den browser die webseite ausliefert
und dann lief das javascript los ja es war relativ beliebt dass man single page applications
macht jetzt vielleicht nicht für so sachen wie youtube aber gerade auch für interna
tools single page applications waren relativ beliebt also sprich du hast quasi deine seite
erstellt zum größten teil in javascript das wurde alles zum client geschickt was meint
ihr warum facebook irgendwie 18 megabit javascript oder so neu leht ohne cash wenn es zum ersten
mal aufmacht und dann würde das alles schön kleinzeitig naja gerendert kann man nicht
sagen es macht immer noch der browser kleinzeitig interaktiv gemacht mit javascript man quasi
komplette package rüber geschickt und dann hat der browser quasi die seite im klein
zusammengebaut ganz ganz früher war das so ganz ganz früher dann hat man ja fast nur
html ausgeliefert und der browser musste die sachen nur rendern die er vom server bekommt
der große vorteil ist von der klassischen variante server side rendering beziehungsweise
dass halt quasi zum größten teil html an browser ausgeliefert wird ist es ist einfach
schnell im rendern euer browser hat die seite bekommen und er kann die seite anzeigen bei
dieser ganzen javascript bei diesem ganzen megabyte weise javascript zeug was darum geschickt
wird ist die erste lade sei es ist das erste laden der seite relativ langsam weil du musst
ja erstmal riesen großen ja pack javascript bekommen dann muss dann browser das erstmal
alles empfangen dann muss der javascript anfangen zu arbeiten dann muss die seite gerendert
werden das dauern dafür kannst du halt hübschere und interaktivere und ja modernere webseiten
machen auf die art und weise und irgendwann sind sie auf die idee gekommen warum verbindet
man das ganze denn nicht irgendwie also sprich warum verbindet man dann nicht server side
rendering und kleinzeit single page applications weil single page applications weil die komplett
aus javascript bestanden waren halt für suchmaschinen auch nicht richtig zu indizieren also sprich
wenn die suchmaschine der seite durchsuchen will und sieht einfach nur ganz viel javascript
und nicht den eigentlichen content der seite dann wirst du nicht gefunden auf google das
natürlich doof so und deswegen hat man sich überlegt wie kann man denn jetzt die vorteile
von server side rendering und bessere suchmaschinen indizierung und alles verbinden mit der interaktivität
von single page applications und dann kam er auf die glorreiche idee man könnte da das
ganze mit mit hydration machen so wie man das nennt das funktioniert folgendermaßen
die webseite wird auf dem server gerendert allerdings inklusive javascript das heißt
man braucht im prinzip deno oder note also das muss in prozine javascript runtime auf
dem server und auf server seite wird die webseite quasi schon initial gerendert allerdings mit
javascript drinnen und dann wird der aktuelle state vom javascript eingepackt mit dem ganzen
html und dem zeug an den client geschickt also dass diesen folgen nennt man dann hydration
das wird quasi eingefroren könnte man so könnte man so nennen also der state wird eingefroren
wird an den client geschickt und der macht dann weiter der dehydrate das dann quasi also
server render die seite einmal komplett mit javascript und allem was dazugehört in den
react view js welt was auch immer single page application oder was auch immer du verwendest
schickts rüber zum client und der macht dann weiter also sprich du hast dann die vorteile
du hast halbwegs schnelle ladezeiten du hast bessere indiziermöglichkeiten von suchmaschinen
und du hast interaktive webseiten für den client ist eigentlich ziemlich cool macht
das next js auch schon ja nukst next und svelte kit und was gibt es dann was gibt es da sonst
noch alles die haben das support für die sache ist halt die das machts halt auch ziemlich
kompliziert zumindest finde ich relativ kompliziert du hast ja dann zig verschiedene sachen du
hast einmal deine backend anwendung wo du dann deine apn points hast oder dein craftql oder
sonst was die kann in dotnet in go in sonst was sein dann hast du deine frontend anwendung
die ist in javascript programmiert und dann brauchst du halt irgendwie noch was was das
server seitlich rendert so sachen wie svelte kit oder nukst ist natürlich ganz nice weil
die machen das für dich aber du brauchst auf jeden fall noch noch ein node zusätzlich
laufen also das machts insgesamt alles auch nicht einfacher da brauche aber auch den
eigenen renderer für jeden einzelnen browser das wird das wird ja nicht gerendert in form
von grafik weil was ich mit rendern meinen auf server seite ist es wird html erzeugt
für den browser also sprich du machst eine webseite mit vue js normalerweise musst du
dass die webseite funktioniert erstmal was weiß ich 5 mb javascript vom server laden
du musst view js vom server laden du musst die ganzen assets runterladen du musst deine
webseiten runterladen dann muss vue js starten und dann muss vue js aus deinem javascript
quasi das html zusammenbauen dass dein browser dann die seite bei dir auf dem bildschirm
anzeigen kann so und was jetzt passiert auf server seite ist dort läuft node js der
led vue js der led alles was die seite braucht und generiert das initiale html was dein browser
machen wird nachdem er das ganze javascript bekommen hat dieses html wie die seite quasi
initial aussehen soll allerdings schon wie das javascript die seite erzeugt hat wird
einmal auf server seite gemacht dann wird der ganze state eingefroren das html an browser
geschickt und dann übernimmt dein browser das die html das rendern das html das geht
schnell weil er initial einmal html rendern kann und dann macht er mit dem ganzen javascript
gedöns weiter also das ist so der aktuelle trend was web was heißt aktuell trend so der
aktuelle stand von webentwicklung wie man kann ich sagen wie man das macht es gibt ja
nie so den einen weg gerade bei webentwicklung aber so eines der angesagten sachen zurzeit
so und jetzt gibt es anscheinend was neues mit resumability also wer heutzutage noch
denkt er macht einen editor auf und schreibt da html und paar dips rein hast du ne ne so
einfach ist das heute nicht mehr unter 5,8 gigabyte npm node modules geht da nix 5,8
gigabyte ist ja nix 120 gigabyte node modules geht da nix nx plus html ist immer noch das
beste das eine hat mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun ok es ist heute netter stream
es ist netter stream ich erkläre mal warum das eine miteinander nichts zu tun hat nx
ist ein webserver der liefert aus was du ihm hinschmeißt der hat mit html schon mal gar
nichts zu tun vielleicht wenn du pap auf server seite machst dann ist es ja so dass
nx das irgendwie zu pap weiterleitet ok das sind aber zwei unterschiedliche paschur nx
ist ein webserver der surft was du ihm hinschmeißt im zweifelsfall auch zip files und html ist
die sprache in der du zumindest also auf in letzter konsequenz deine webseite dem browser
hin wirft html schreiben ist ja heute nur die halbe miete im prinzip wird ja ganz viel
von dem html eben von javascript erzeugt was der browser dann am ende halt anzeigt
jetzt verstehe ich das war als witz gemeint oder tschie bait jetzt habe ich verstanden
ok ich habe ich habe ich habe gebraucht das war das war nicht so gemein ja ja genau du
machst das quasi wie wie bann oder so du integrierst das alles bringt quasi webseite raus der hatte
was auch immer wie das aussehen soll cringe genau richtig das war das war entweder war
das zu low oder zu high IQ für mich der witz ich ich lecke critical information könnte
man sozusagen sozusagen sagen ja he doesn't know he lacks critical information
er meint lau mit engine x und html dass man leichter eine webseite zu hosten kann es ergibt
aber auch nicht viel sinn in dem kontext dann ich meine ich kann mit jedem x beliebig in
webserver einfach html seiten hosten dafür sind webserver aber ursprünglich erfunden
worden ich kann auch in pyson one liner in der steinzeit webentwicklung ja gut wie gesagt
dafür sind webs dafür sind ach ok ok was du machen kannst ist du kannst in deine engine
x konfig reinschreiben inline html vielleicht ja dass du ihm quasi eine antwort direkt
reinschreibst aber das hat man glaube ich auch selbst früher nicht gemacht weil hat
er html dateien hingelegt die dann der webserver ausgeliefert hat also egal wir gucken jetzt
das video weiter und ohne hier shadow witzig ich wollte ich wollte es gerade sagen ich war
ohne scheiß ich wollte gerade das gleiche sagen wollte ich sagen ohne den komponentes
cluster kann es heute kein server mehr betreiben kein service mehr betreiben das muss horizontal
vertikal diagonal und über kreuz skalieren dann brauchst du natürlich noch helm dashboards
fabio load balancer ähm zertifikats und secret verwaltung also ja unter unter 5000 euro
im monat aws rechnung oder google cloud oder azure ist da nix was empfiehlst du um eine
karriere in richtung defops er sich dafür interessieren ist schon mal das erste das
ist das erste und das mit abstand wichtigste dich für technologien interessieren aus diesem
bereich das ist ja das definiert ja auch jeder ein bisschen anders das def das definiert
ja auch jeder ein bisschen als hauptsächlich sagen wir so eine sache glaube ich wo man
so durch die bank weg sagen kann was was denke ich bei 90 prozent der fällen bei in defops
teams oder bei bei defops leuten die vielleicht aus der administration kommen ist da kommen
da wird sich oft um entwickler tools und tools im allgemeinen gekümmert sei es jetzt um
automatisierung für irgendwelche cloud infrastruktur oder um irgendwelche bild pipelines für
entwickler in die integrations ci cd server solche geschichten ist glaube ich was was
glaube ich 90 prozent aller leute die irgendwas mit defops im titel haben wohl mehr oder weniger
was mit zu tun haben ab und zu mal so über den lauf also man kann nicht sagen dass das
der hauptbestandteil ist aber das machen viele das ist bei vielen bestandteil der arbeit
ansonsten kann ich das jetzt so schlecht sagen
traffic vom engine x und custom reverse proxy davor klar man könnte man könnte auch noch
man könnte auch noch eine proxy davor machen triple load balancer ist ausfallsicherer
wenn du dich für geld interessierst dann musst du big stonks aktien kaufen und dann
bist du gleich oder arm richtig die die bahn war tatsächlich gestern pünktlich
traffic ist in go ja das ist richtig traffic ist nicht in was ich weiß gar nicht gibt
es den moment github rust web server rust load balancer ach du scheiße natürlich gibt
es das netter stream sorry natürlich gibt es das ok vor sieben jahren war wohl nicht
so erfolgreich auch nicht tja da hat keiner bock so was komplexes mit rust zu machen obwohl
das plays in die fastware was pingora davon habe ich jetzt noch nie was gehört github
da kennt es kenne ich nicht was ist das
was nee nee nee das ist irgendwas anderes das ist nichts was du als web server verwendest
ja jenkins jenkins ist old school jenkins ist richtig richtig old school github actions
ist zum beispiel aber ohne scheiß ich persönlich mag jenkins noch aber ich bin ja boomer was
das angeht ich mag ja auch so was wie nagios können euch das vorstellen die meisten leute
denken ich hab sie nicht mal wenn ich sage ich mag nagios aber ich mag tatsächlich nagios
nicht dass ich bei mir daheim nagios freiwillig betreiben würde noch 2022 aber ich mag
prinzipiell nagios
gibt es auf github pingora github alles was es nicht auf github gibt gibt es bei mir
nicht
ok wir kommen jetzt endlich das video fertig
war lighthouse nichtmal dieser performance test der mal auf twitter irgendeinen shitstorm
ausgelöst hat weil irgendeiner erzählt hat oder war das lighthouse so vor 2-3 jahren ich
kann mich noch dunkel daran erinnern irgendeinen performance benchmark hatte mal so ein mini
shitstorm auf twitter ausgelöst weil sie irgendwelche libraries benachteiligt haben
und dann der entwickler gesagt hat dann der entwickler irgendwie geschrieben hat auf twitter
das ist doch nur keine ahnung er war nicht schwarz ich sag mal nur singelmäßig das
ist doch nur weil ich schwarz bin und dann hat sich dann irgendeiner übelst drüber
aufgeregt dass jetzt irgendwelche library autoren diskriminiert werden war das nicht
lighthouse da war doch vor ein paar jahren mal irgendwas in der richtung irgendwas habe
ich da noch im hinterkopf riesiger riesiges rumgeflame um nix war das vor ein paar jahren
wieder alles lighthouse das war damals voll ich kann auch sein dass ich das jetzt total
falsch wiedergegeben habe ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern aber es war was
in dieser richtung und da war wieder so richtig unsinniger shitstorm vor ein paar jahren am
start wenn lighthouse von google ist dann war das was anderes was ich meine da war aber
auf jeden fall irgendwas ich krieg es nicht mal richtig zusammen und es war irgendjemand
da bin ich mir relativ sehr es war irgendein browser benchmark tool aber mal davon abgesehen
leute haltet es für so so haltet es für so unwahrscheinlich dass sowas passiert ist selbst
wenn ich mir jetzt nicht mehr genau dran erinnern kann nein an das war wir hatten letztens auf
der arbeit eine diskussion ob main oder master aber haltet es wirklich für so für uns unwahrscheinlich
dass sowas passiert heutzutage was irgendjemand hier der irgendeiner irgendeine der ganzen
runtimes nach was nochmal ich kann es kann ich jetzt mal spaß irgendwer hier der irgendeine
der ganzen runtimes nach node js verwendet ich weiß nicht was du meinst achso du meinst
einer hat sie nach node js gekommen sind deno bahn was gibt es da sonst noch alles also
außer dass deno und bahn sehr viele github sterne haben habe ich ehrlich gesagt noch
nichts gesehen wo das verwendet wurde und ich glaube auch nicht dass beides sowohl deno
als auch bahn wirklich ja im business sektor klingt immer doof aber sagen wir also ich
versuche nur weil es ein paar projekte auf github gibt die das verwenden heißt noch
lange nicht dass es irgendwie relevant ist und selbst wenn es ein großes github projekt
gibt dann ist vielleicht dieses projekt relevant aber nicht zwangsläufig das worin es programmiert
wurde und ich sehe es jetzt nicht dass deno und bahn irgendwie im business umfeld ankommen
würden genauso wie rust zum beispiel auch noch nicht aber für rust bei rust ist es
halt so rust ist keine sprache für so 0815 projekte die man normalerweise im business
enterprise stonks umfeld macht ja also ich arbeite bei einer bank und die machen da
garantiert kein rust projekt weil für was vielleicht vielleicht für irgendwelche ibm
mainframe geschichten wenn das gehen sollte wo alles super korrekt sein muss und was auch
immer aber selbst dafür da geht es ja eher darum dass das ding richtig rechnet und weniger
dass das ding 100 prozent memory safe ist und so viel performance hat wie es brauche
ich meine die machen ja kein high frequency trading oder sowas und selbst da ist besser
es ist schnell als dass es abkackt also es gibt für rust sagen wir eine recht schmalen
ein recht schmales anwendungsspektrum wo das richtig sinnvoll ist von dem was es bietet
der vorteil von rust ist ja nochmal eindeutig performance gepaart mit so gut wie möglich
memory safety das ist das was dir rust bringt also wenn du was sicherheitsrelevantes programmierst
zum beispiel was gleichermaßen auch noch saumäßig schnell sein soll dann nimmst du rust für
normale sachen nimmst du eigentlich kein rust außer rust fanboys die blazingly fast written
mit rust in ihr repo schreiben wollen und um zum üben natürlich also das ist der anwendungszweck
man muss sich ja auch mal überlegen wo rust herkommt chat wer weiß es woher kommt rust
wer hat rust erfunden und warum hat der rust erfunden wer ist wer ist heute der wer gewinnt
in hrq reward der pips hat gewonnen korrekt mozilla unter anderem für war geplant eine
neue cs css engine für firefox und wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin ob es das überhaupt
jemals geschafft hat aber viele innereien von firefox sind heute in rust und ein browser
zumindest in thailand ist natürlich was wo man sagen kann ja da macht rust sinn beim
bei einem browser ist jedes fitzelchen an performance wichtig allerdings auch dass das
ding sicher ist irgendwelchen sinnlosen overflows underflows out of bounds index gedöns willst
du in dem browser nicht haben und schon gar nicht in der javascript runtime oder was was
in irgendeiner art und weise beeinflusst werden kann von webseiten weil ansonsten hast du
mal relativ schnell irgendeinen exploit dass du aus der sandbox von einem browser ausbrechen
kannst und für sowas ist rast natürlich geradezu gemacht weil rust ist schnell rast ist so
sicher wie es sein kann ohne quasi alles jedes mal beim zugriff zu checken na out of memory
ist was anderes das ist ein anderes problem der braucht einfach zu viel memory so also
dafür dafür ist halt rust gemacht deswegen glaube ich nicht dass rust sich nennenswert
im enterprise umfeld durchsetzen wird weil es ist einfach zu aufwendig rust software
zu entwickeln im vergleich zu sagen wir mal java finde doch mal entwickler die ahnung
von rust haben gibt es nicht so viele reden wir jetzt beispielsweise für irgendwelche
microcontroller geschichte zum beispiel noch ein anderer fall ja jemand der irgendwelche
steuerungs sachen für seine controller im auto programmieren will da kann ich würde
ich zum beispiel verstehen wenn man das mit rust macht ja du hast irgendeine steuerung
für elektroauto und brauchst du irgendeine steuerung für die bremsen oder für die ansteuerung
vom akku und solche geschichten das willst du dass es schnell ist weil du willst ja da
nicht super teure hardware reinstecken ja das soll auch auf schwache hardware sehr performant
laufen und du willst nicht dass es krascht es darf nicht kraschen und es muss schnell
sein und am möglichkeit sollten sie leute auch nicht einfach exploiten können und dafür
ist rust gut so und deswegen wird sich selbst rust und rust ist eines der beliebtesten programmiersprachen
zur zeit was das github was die github umfrage angeht und selbst das setzt sich eher zögerlich
und in manchen business feldern gar nicht durch rust das heißt da muss man mit so sachen
wie deno und bann es gar nicht ankommen ich meine mir ist auch klar dass deno und bann
keine programmiersprachen sind sondern javascript runtimes beziehungsweise typescript runtimes
aber es ist im prinzip der gleiche ansatz sprich node.js ist einfach der standard er
verbreitet es es gibt 30 millionen npm module für so gut wie alles was geht und du findest
leute die ahnung von node.js haben und node funktioniert eigentlich auch nicht schlecht
warum sollte man deno und bann nehmen im business enterprise umfeld also ich glaube nicht dass
es das irgendwie da sich durchsetzt die sonntag ist abartig kryptisch von rust ja wie gesagt
die master main diskussion hatten wir auch letztens auf der arbeit ja so ist es so ist
es bei uns auch ich habe master ehrlich gesagt aus dem einzigen grund noch weil es die fault
anstellung ist und ich mich so sehr dran gewöhnt habe auf der arbeit haben wir zum größten
teil main und wir hatten letztens wir hatten letztens diskussionen auf master oder main
branch weil irgendjemand sein altes repo wo das ding seit jahren jahrzehnten gefühlt
schon master heißt nach gitter pushen wollte und irgendeiner gemeint hat nein nein dann
musst du es umbenennen nach mein nach main und er meint ich muss gar nichts umbenennen
das können wir bei neuen repos machen aber meinem alten repo lassen wir so da gab es
riesen diskussion total hängen geblieben da überhaupt drüber zu diskutieren ja das glaube
ich das glaube ich auch embedded javascript in was ist das embedded also wenn man sich
mal anguckt was im bus das enterprise umfeld beliebt ist dann sind das sachen die es schon
ewig gibt und auch ewig geben wird da ist beliebt java ist beliebt dotnet wenn wir von
legacy anwendung anfangen wahrscheinlich auch noch kobold java dotnet javascript logischerweise
und selbst bei so sachen wie go mittlerweile auch zum teil aber selbst bei so sachen wie
go ist es nicht dass du sagen würdest du hast so wirklich viele projekte vielleicht
bei irgendwelchen startups oder so aber nicht nicht im bankumfeld wo ich arbeite da ist
die meiste sachen die meisten sachen java manche sachen bei uns also unsere software
besteht im prinzip zu 95 prozent aus kobold auf mainframe lasst mal weg zu 95 prozent
aus java javascript und dotnet also so total ist nur nach 15 zeug aber dafür dafür findest
du halt auch entwickler was ja nicht ganz unwichtig ist und du kannst davon ab davon
ausgehen die waren die letzten 15 jahre da und die sind auch in weiteren 15 jahre da
und kobold auch noch in 80 fresh war das dino framework ja ja habe ich haben wir sogar im
stream zusammen gemacht ist das gut wenn man einfach webkram mit c sharp machen will weiß
jetzt nicht mehr auf was ich es bezieht aber es ist die scharpe bzw asp.net core ist wunderbar
für web backends für deine api endpunkte unter auch für den craft ql endpunkt oder
auch für einen grpc endpunkt mittlerweile ist wunderbar frontend für java es gibt
gui geschichten für den desktop web keine ahnung es hat bestimmt irgendjemand verrückt
ist schon das gibt es bestimmt auch als web assembly es haben bestimmt schon irgendwelche
verrückten java runtime in web assembly portiert garantiert ja das ist normal das ist normal
dass jede woche neue tools angesagt sind und die dann eine woche später keinen mehr interessieren
man muss das mit der zeit so ein bisschen mit der zeit kann man das ein bisschen ausfiltern
also muss nicht wirklich auf alles was geben was da mal so durchs dorf getrieben wird wieder
aber man sollte zumindest immer so ein auge und ein ohr so ein bisschen offen haben und
gucken ja zum beispiel man ab und zu mal die fire ship videos gucken wenn was neues ist
vielleicht nicht ab und zu mal wenn es was neues auf hackernews gibt oder auf reddit
angepriesen wird man mal bei github reingucken was ist denn das überhaupt so dass man ein
bisschen was gesehen hat man muss damit nicht gleich irgendein projekt machen außer man
ist sehr stress und und frust tolerant rust ist produktiveres c++ also ich glaube bist
du mein c++ ist auch müll ja aber ich glaube bist du in rust den punkt erreicht hast dass
du produktiver bist als c++ ist dauert ein bisschen also rast sundags und auch der permanente
kampf gegen den borrower checker gut da gewöhnt man sich dran ist schon ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
und das problem an c++ ist halt der vorteil von c++ ist halt dass irgendwie jeder der
mal ein bisschen was in c style sprachen gemacht hat was hinrotzen kann das funktioniert da
nicht richtig durchblicken tut bei c++ auch keiner und in sich logisch ist es definitiv
auch nicht da ist was schon eindeutig vorne aber schnell was machen ist glaube ich c++
immer noch eine ganze ecke vor rust eher weniger ich denke mal es gibt schon die ein oder anderen
projekte aber das meiste es gibt realistisch betrachtet gibt es doch was spieleentwicklung
angeht aktuell zwei sachen es gibt unreal es gibt unity und es gibt vielleicht in welcher
sprache ist das überhaupt es ist auf jeden fall nicht also auf jeden fall nicht go auch
wenn er was von go drinne steht und das ist so eines der kommenden sachen aber bei den
großen ist es doch es ist doch eigentlich nur unity und unreal also das heißt du hast
die auswahl zwischen c++ und c++ engine oder c++ engine und sie scharpe game es irritiert
das immer als ich sage immer c++ aber es gibt auch leute die sagen jetzt ist es habe
ich gar nicht mehr im kopf c++ die betonen das so komisch c++ ich sag c++ und was kann
der z plus plus ich schwachsache aber irritiert mich immer wenn ich leute die sagen c++ ok
weird champ ich glaube ich bin mit dem chat heute nicht mal fertig bei rust habe ich da
so meine zweifel embedded cs in einer rust anwendung jetzt gehts aber hier richtig zur
sache achso wir wollten das video fertig gucken lull score ist to use less javascript google
did some science and found that making a site 20 ich wüsste ich wüsste eigentlich ausmachen
jetzt egal wir gucken das video noch fertig so faster results in 10 percent more conversions
if your website makes a thousand dollars a year that could be like ten dollars you're leaving
on the table the catch 22 of web development is that in order to implement the features
your customers want you need more javascript javascript javascript javascript javascript
like an xjs for example you start with about 70 kilobytes of javascript out of the gate
thanks to react on you'll then add at least und das und das ist noch nicht mal wie gesagt
ladet mal facebook oder youtube oder sonst was machen wir jetzt nicht normalerweise hätte
ich es jetzt gemacht ladet das mal ohne cash alter ihr werdet leute kein wunder dass man
früher mit den alten mobile tarifen nicht ausgekommen ist ein paar hundert more kilobytes
zu dreimal youtube refreshed und dein datentarif war voll das ist im prinzip das was ich eben
erklärt habe
component tree from the ground up it's kind of like watching a movie that can't be paused
if you need to restart the application by hitting the refresh button in the browser it needs
to re-execute all the javascript from the beginning to get back to where it was frameworks like
astro have recognized this problem which uses a technique astro astro wollte ich auch mal
hier ausprobieren mit euch zusammen im stream astro macht das ja mit wie heißt das javascript
islands oder so was da kannst du dann sagen ja ok hier oben so dieses diese komponente
meine keine ahnung mein news ticker oder so da ist jetzt interaktiv und javascript der
rest ist statisches html
partial hydration to selectively hydrate the dom but quick cuts out hydration altogether
like it's just not even necessary it delivers html that's instantly
ja wir wollten schon viel im stream ausprobieren aber wir haben auch schon viel im stream ausprobiert
you should be able to achieve es geht uns nicht aus
no matter how big and complex your javascript codebase is that sounds too good to be true
so how is it even possible the key innovation here is that a quick app can be fully serialized
as html in other words at any moment you can liste wird noch länger and capture all the
data and closures in the application and represented all as an html string that's huge for server
side rendering because by the is das nicht das gleiche wie hydration time that html gets
to the browser it can just pick up where the server left off without needing to execute
any javascript
es ist doch das gleiche wie hydration was da was da gerade erzählt
okay jetzt kommt's
ahh okay
Wir können sehen, dass dieser Event-Handler direkt in die Kode geserialisiert wird.
Wenn wir nun den Netzwerk-Tab öffnen, werden wir 0 JavaScript auf dem Initial-Page-Load finden.
Ihr werdet bemerken, dass das JavaScript nicht tatsächlich ausgeladen wird, bis wir klicken.
Es enthält den Code, den wir auslösen wollen, und es hat auch Zugang zu dem lexischen Umfeld, um zu updaten.
Das heißt, er ruckelt erst mal eine Sekunde, wenn er viel nachladen muss, beim Button-Press.
... das von anderen Komponenten geteilt wird, welches selbst aus einer anderen, lässigen, ausgeladenen Teile kommt.
The takeaway here is that you don't actually need to load any JavaScript until the user interacts with the UI.
Ah, okay. Jetzt, jetzt habe ich's... Jetzt habe ich's verstanden.
...tiny chunks, less than one kilobyte each, instead of a single, massive bundle.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau.
...to as much JavaScript as your heart desires.
Das ist... Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau.
I've had enough.
This has been the Code Report. Thanks for watching, and I will...
Auf der anderen Seite, es ist im Prinzip quasi Hydration mit gestökelter Dehydration.
So quasi, ähm... den Stand quasi nach wie vor einfrieren.
Allerdings dann, ähm... das Zurückwandeln, das dann in Häppchen.
Ah, ja, okay. Das ist tatsächlich nicht blöd, muss ich sagen.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool.
Wie JavaScript Frameworks innerhalb von drei Wochen irgendwie einfach mal 8000 Sterne haben, Leute.
Wisst ihr, was mein letztes Projekt auf GitHub, wie viele Sterne das hat?
Elf.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, kann man das auch nicht vergleichen.
Ich gebe... Ich gestehe ja der Sache zu, ein JavaScript Framework ist bestimmt für mehr Leute interessant
als eine Home Assistant-Integration, wo man die Daten von seinem Fiat-Auto in seine Heimautomatisierung übertragen kann.
Aber trotzdem krass, wie schnell JavaScript Frameworks da...
Das müssen wir, glaube ich, auch mal ausprobieren im Stream.
Aber, das schreibe ich mal in meine Stream-Ideen rein.
Ich glaube, mein Plugin wäre auch oder mein Addon wäre auch beliebter, wenn es Placingly Fast und Written in Rust wäre.
Oder zumindest in Go. Zumindest in Go hätte ich es ja mal machen können.
Weil der Coolness-Faktor ist schon... Ist schon eindeutig niedriger in Go als in Rust.
Aber.NET hat wirklich kein Coolness-Faktor auf GitHub.
Ich glaube, ich gucke mir dazu mal ein Tutorial an und dann überlege ich mir, ob das...
...was ist, was ich mal ausprobieren will hier im Stream.
Okay, Leute, jetzt muss ich aber wirklich ins Bett.
Äh, Fanatics, frag mich das nächste Stream nochmal, dann sage ich was zu, habe ich schon was mitgemacht, ja?
Äh, mit zwei von den drei Sachen. Also, wir sehen uns. Bis denn, CU.